did Transformers rise of the Beast claw
its way into fans hearts or does it
belong in a junkyard Twitter has some
strong opinions for nearly as long as
Transformers have occupied toy Isles
around the world they've called Cinemas
their second home from the 1986 animated
feature to director Michael Bay's
live-action films from the 2000s into
the 2010s generations have flogged to
theaters to watch The Honorable Autobots
and the villainous Decepticons to battle
in space on Earth and everywhere in
between after some years away from the
big screen the robots in Disguise are
back for the action-packed adventure
Transformers rise of the Beast courtesy
of director Stephen cable Jr and
Paramount Pictures influenced by the
Transformers Beast War Saga rise of the
Beast Autobots in the middle of a
battle like no other the dangerous
Unicron serving terracons have arrived
on Earth seeking a powerful artifact
known as the transwarp key to keep it
out of their hands Autobots have to join
forces with an animalistic faction known
as the maximors as well as a handful of
human companions who are swept up in the
Raging conflict well that sounds like an
entertaining enough Blockbuster plot on
paper what's it like in reality
Transformers right to the Beast has
kicked off its theatrical run and those
have already gone to check it out have
some strong opinions on what the film
has to offer as reactions have begun to
pop up all over Twitter it appears that
a great deal of Transformers fans are
really happy with their latest
movie-going Experience One user wrote
just watch Transformers rise of the
Beast that was so awesome like just so
cool I was smiling like a freaking kid
coming out to the cinema another Twitter
user touted the film's fun factor and
expressed hope that it's enough for it
to do well at the global box office and
while they admitted that the writing is
a bit lacking and the action is
uninspired a third fan light rise of the
Beast overall and is more than happy
with the movie's character work
there you go now we're friends also
giving the feature of positive
assessment one user noted that it's up
against some stiff competition in the
form of the recently released Spider-Man
across the spider-verse rather than
floundering though they feel it managed
to thrive up against a widely adored
animated film one of the highlights for
one fan is the film's 1990s setting
which is particularly prevalent in the
New York City set First Act they
commented the opening act in 90s NYC is
particularly delightful and the hip-hop
soundtrack from that era is fabulous
even as countless Transformers fans
rushed to Twitter to express her
adoration for Rise of the Beast others
were quick to Spotlight some of the
film's more disappointing elements one
fan took to Twitter to say that they
feel that the cast of human characters
doesn't do much to elevate the story a
problem they believe has persisted
throughout the live-action Transformers
movies
one fan shared in their tweet that even
though rise of the Beast tries some new
things from their perspective it does
far too many of the things that happen
in every other Transformers movie
writing Sky beams fake house and trying
to build a Cinematic Universe it's a
mixed bag in that same vein another
Twitter user said of the film's
narrative shortcomings it could have
benefited from a previous movie or two I
think there really could have been some
big time World building with the Maximus
I think they suffer the most in the
movie one thing that one fan feels rise
of the Beast doesn't have in common with
its predecessors is the quality of CGI
to them even though the technology has
come a long way since 2007's
Transformers the visuals have somehow
gotten worse if you want to form your
own opinion Transformers rise of the
Beast is now in theaters which means
there's only one thing to do transform
and roll out